what's up everyone welcome to program
your Ramon today we're going to be
looking at a forward flip key
programming procedure this procedure is
gonna be for if your vehicle takes the
flip key it will not work if your
vehicle has push-button start so in
order to get started we need to already
working flip keys and then we have our
new unprogrammed flip key and on the
unprogrammed flip key you're gonna have
to get the key cut prior to being able
to do this procedure that'll be the only
part you can't do yourself
so once you get yourself to that point
where we have our two already working
keys and our new unprogrammed flip key
with the blade cut we can get into the
next step okay so now we're ready to get
started we have our two already
programmed keys and we have our new key
so we're gonna take our first already
programmed key put it in the ignition
turn it to on for about a second two
seconds turn to off remove now within
three seconds but not longer than 10
seconds put our second program key in
turn it to on turn it to off remove now
we have our new unprogrammed key and
we're gonna do the same thing put it in
the ignition turn it to on turn turn it
to off you probably heard the door lock
cycle there that's gonna indicate that
this remote success we've been
programmed remove now let's go ahead and
test the remote door locks work let's
make sure it starts the vehicle
and that's working on moe thanks for
watching everyone if you could take a
second please like and subscribe helps
us out and we'd appreciate it